معنى الالم من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك
اللواء دويري يعني تصعيد لافت في القرن
اليوم وتدمير للمسيرات الاوكرانيه
بالتزامن مع وصول دبابات ابرامز قبل وقتها
الى المشهد الاوكراني برايك ما اهميه وصول
مثل هذه الدبابات الان الى ساحه المعركه
يعني اولا يجب ان نتوقف عند العدد الذي تم
التصريح به وهو الرقم الاجمالي 31 دبابه
اي مجموعه قتال الذي وصل بناء على بعض
التقارير 11 ذبابه اي فريق قتال او سريه
الان السؤال فريق القتال هذا او سريه
الدبابات كيف يمكن توظيفها في هذه الحرب
الحاليه لانها اعداد محدوده جدا وهذه
الدبابه رغم انها الافضل في العالم لكن
هناك طرحت تساؤلات حول امكانيه
ملائمتها لطبيعه القتال في اوكرانيا لماذا
لان هذه الدبابه تعتبر اليوبارد اكثر
ملائمه لجمله اسباب فنيه اهمها
دبابه ابرامز وزنها يتراوح ما بين 69 الى
73.3 طن اي دبابه ثقيله جدا
محرك تورتيني نفاس
يستخدم الكورسين الخاص بالطائرات وبالتالي
استهلاك وقود عاليه جدا نظام صياني معقد
وهناك خوفا من سقوطها بيد الجناب الاخر
هذه الامور تحدد طبيعه الدور المستقبلي
لتوظيفها وانا ارى ان اوكرانيا ستميل
تلك الصعوبات التي اشرت اليها لماذا
التشديد الاوكراني على يعني الحصول على
مثل هذه الدبابات مع صعوبه كما تقول
استخدامها
لسبب اخر هذه الدبابه انا قلت هي الافضل
في العالم الدبابه اصلا وجدت القيام
بعمليات تعرضيه ولكن يمكن استخدامها بدور
دفاعي هذه الدبابات ست ستكون مثاليه اذا
ما استخدمت بالادوار الدفاعيه لماذا لديها
قوه نار لديها قابليه حركه لديها حمايه
مدرعه ايجابي وسلبي ولديها نظام سيطره
متميز جدا فاذا ما استخدمت بالادوار
الدفاعيه ستكون قادره جدا على صد الهجمات
الروسيه وقادره جدا على حمايه الخطوط
الدفاعيه لكن استخدامها في الادوار
الهجوميه يجب ان تكون اكثر من هذا نعم
ستقدم اضافه لكنها اضافه محدوده لان
الاعداد قليله يعني كانت في الادوار
الدفاعيه هل يمكن ان تغير في مسار المعارك
تلك الدبابات
نعم ستغير لكن انا اقول لك نحن نتحدث عن
فريق قتال نحن نتحدث عن اصغر وحده قتاليه
تستخدم بها الدبابات يعني الان الدبابات
نتحدث عن دورها اذا كانت بحجم فرقه 300
دبابه او بحجم لواء مئه دبابه او مجموعه
قتال بحجم 33 دبابه انا اتحدث عن سريه
دبابات يعني دور محدود جدا والوظائف التي
تسند لها يجب ان تتلاعم مع قدراتها
العدديه لهذا السبب يعني لا اود ان اضخم
كثيرا من مفاعيل التي تقدمها بسبب ليس نوع
الدبابه وكفاءته بسبب الاعداد التي ارسلت
شكرا لك لواء فايز دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه كنت تبعنا من عمان